while the government celebrated the
opposition sat back in their seats
visibly taken aback and dejected
it's essential or no confidence motion
is constitutional I reject this
resolution
they'd called for a no-confidence vote
blaming prime minister Imran Khan for
the Steep rise in inflation and what
they call his anti-western foreign
policy within minutes of the Deputy
speaker's shock announcement Imran Khan
made a televised National address
now that the speaker has exercised his
constitutional power I have advised the
president to dissolve the assembly so
that democracy prevails in a Democratic
Society we conduct elections so that the
public choose who they want to leave
their country
the president obliged dramatic scenes in
the National Assembly A fitting climax
for this political crisis in the run-up
to this vote we've had Revelations of a
plot to assassinate Imran Khan and an
expose on alleged collusion between
opposition MPS and a foreign country he
accidentally named as a United States to
intervene in Pakistan's politics and
oust him through this vote of low
confidence and that's what the speaker
cited when rejecting today's votes
Shame Shame claimed imran's party the
opposition says these allegations are
baseless and it's Imran Khan who is
acting unconstitutionally in a desperate
bid to hold on to power as per the
Constitution the voting on the vote of
no confidence against the Prime Minister
was to be held today there is no
negotiability on that in the
Constitution that was not done Imran
Khan says he's a Target because of his
refusal to side with the United States
and his recent trip to meet with
President Putin he says he went to
Moscow as a peacemaker but even by
Pakistan's tumultuous political
standards it's been a chaotic crisis
Simon Mawson Sky News Islamabad